I think there's a lot of humor in this
show yeah I'm funny you're very funny
when you're without filter which causes
my character a lot of problems
[Music]
so episode 3 starts when I'm letting
Lucia and Mia out of my room and you see
that good morning
and I ask you please don't say anything
about any of this that I'll be okay Dad
please look at those cannolis you have a
bit of a loose tongue and you don't I
don't know if that's deliberate or just
Occidental I don't speak with forked
tongue I guess so I made a plan for us
today you should come that's okay she's
coming
I think Dominic's fine with Porsha
coming along he's happy to see his son
make a connection with someone
especially in a smart nice you know
young woman I think that my character is
delighted to have a young attractive
woman around he's very concerned about
still being attractive to women who are
one-third his age he's a little bit
unrealistic in other words he's just as
common 82 year old guy he's not going to
go gentle into that good night not bird
and I love him for that
do we embarrass you I'll be
no it's just I don't think you realize
how you sound sometimes what Alby brings
is a balance to our point of view and
the perspective that it otherwise
wouldn't exist not in our world he's
helping Bert to look at himself and he
certainly is helping your character my
character is learning from both you and
him in some ways he feels closer to some
of the ways you grew up in some ways he
feels closer to Alby and he doesn't want
to make the same mistakes he has made a
lot of the same mistakes you did but he
wants to be able to transcend them and
he's looking towards Alby to help him in
a way and he's kind of caught between
both of those places I need to change so
I don't think I'm going to be able to
meet up at all this week this is for the
ladies
[Music]
Jennifer's character just tickles me to
death yeah I was gonna say the same yeah
she's a real hand and yeah she's a real
who that's a good way to put it she'd be
the most fun probably
[Music]
I personally like to go with the flow I
might have a couple of things like I
want to do this I want to see that I
don't like going on tours very much or
being with other people that I don't
know like on some kind of tour I I find
that kind of confining but you know I
always do a little bit of research and
pick a point of going to see some things
that are interesting
people are considering how many clothes
this guy's wearing I'm not going to
carry that stuff I don't mind checking
luggage check it baby
[Music]
I travel a lot just like you do and
after a long trip you get up five
o'clock in the morning that's a great
time to go out and see a city yeah you
own the place you walk around and you
get a pretty good idea of your bearings
that's the way I like to travel yeah and
then you know in the afternoon you
collapse yeah me too I'm an early riser
thank you